welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for Christopher Nolan's
Oppenheimer coming July 21st 2023 with
Killian Murphy it's j Robert Oppenheimer
the physicist who led the Manhattan
Project to develop the atomic bomb
during World War II this trailer imagery
produces a mix of Terror and awe mass
destruction seen Through The Eyes of a
scientist obsessed with poetry and
religion I know you Nolan heads are
eating this [ __ ] up so let's break down
this trailer to explain the history of
this complicated and fascinating
historical figure and how this really
could be Christopher Nolan's first
horror film I mean I don't know I guess
insomnia was kind of scary but I feel
like this is a movie that's going to
leave us with some nightmares we open on
the Roar of flames and Sparks as we are
literally seeing the air Catching Fire
this is probably the film's depiction of
the Trinity test in New Mexico the
world's first successful detonation of
an atomic bomb July 16th 1945 just a few
weeks before similar bombs were dropped
over Nagasaki in Hiroshima Christopher
Nolan actually shot this explosion
practically on location in New Mexico
but using Miniatures but still he made
something go boom shot on 65 millimeter
film this Trinity test was the atomic
test I witnessed by Oppenheimer himself
and I'm expecting it to be the climax of
the film Oppenheimer reportedly named
the test Trinity after the holy sonnets
a poet John Dunn others believed by
oppenheimer's relationship with the
psychiatrist Gene tatlock who will be
played by Florence Pugh in this film oh
and by the way though this trailer
doesn't show it this cast is stuck Emily
Blunt is playing Kitty Oppenheimer J
Robert's wife Matt Damon is playing
oppenheimer's boss General Leslie Groves
who directed The Manhattan Project
Robert Downey Jr plays Louis Strauss a
founding commissioner of the U.S atomic
energy commission a guy who really
disliked Oppenheimer did not like his
politics at all it's actually Robert
Downey Jr Strauss that we heard at the
end of the first teaser the man who
moved the Earth this cast also includes
Rami Malek Kenneth Brana Jack Quaid as
Richard Feynman and Gary Oldman as
President Harry Truman whose voice we
also heard in that teaser the force from
which the sun draws its power has been
loose that was taken directly from
Truman's televised address after the
bombs were dropped on Japan the first
from which the sun draws his power has
been loose now this powerful and
beautiful music in this film is being
composed by Ludovic jorenson who worked
with Nolan on tenets actually if you
remember Christopher Nolan referenced
Oppenheimer in a scene and tenant you're
familiar with the Manhattan Project
as they approach the first atomic test
openham became concerned that the
detonation might produce a chain
reaction and cutting the world they went
ahead anyway and got lucky think of a
scientist as her Generations
she devises a method for inverting the
world it becomes convinced that by
destroying us the destroying themselves
so in a way Oppenheimer is a historical
prequel to tenant at least in the mind
of Christopher Nolan and the things that
keep him up at night over shots of
oppenheimer's eye-opening rain and the
Los Alamos lab site Oppenheimer says we
imagine a future
and our imaginings horrifiers the
visuals of burning air might actually be
what is an oppenheimer's mind long
before the bombs go off the nightmarish
future that only he and other scientists
can visualize and are struggling to
properly illustrate the scale of to
everyone else Oppenheimer says they
won't fear it
until they understand it and they won't
understand it
until they've used it and in the lab we
see the Assembly of what I assume to be
the gadget the code name for the
implosion plutonium bomb that was
detonated at Trinity and to talk briefly
about the engineering of this thing the
sphere was made of two hemispheres of a
plutonium gallium alloy plated with
silver silver that from the radiation
within blistered and had to be filed
down and then just covered in gold foil
later cores were plated with nickel and
then this was covered in an aluminum
Pusher shell and then surrounded by
these pentagonal pieces is that you see
them plugging in here these are actually
conventional explosives that would all
detonate and squeeze the plutonium-239
pit to critical mass that would then
react with the uranium-235 underneath it
to create the process of nuclear fission
in which atoms are split apart releasing
a tremendous amount of energy though not
as much as Fusion that would later be
the case with hydrogen bombs and I just
love the shot here of Oppenheimer
watching this spear get surrounded by
these charges essentially the radiation
sealed up in a tomb up and I were
knowing the next time he will see this
radiation will be when it lights up the
freaking Sky manifesting the horrors of
his nightmares but then this fear cross
dissolves into a jar of marbles placed
beside a wine glass filled with marbles
probably a scene from Berkeley where
nuclear fission is demonstrated in
classroom setting Nolan includes more
macroscopic imagery of Lights swirling
and dancing showing us atomic particles
interacting with each other which has a
certain Beauty to it but also a certain
Terror now I'm on camera a lot so I have
to see my face a lot so you think I
would have to put a lot of effort in my
skincare routine but you know what I
really don't because I use geology
geology is a 15 time award-winning
personalized skin care company
recognized in hypebeast Verde Men's
Health and Esquire and Aspen grooming
Awards with over 6 000 5 Star reviews
and they've recently expanded to offer
products for pretty much whatever you
need all you got to do is take this 30
second diagnostic quiz and geology is
going to figure out your routine for you
like if you need some hair care well use
geology's co-wash it's a specially
formulated cream cleanser that removes
buildup and cleanses the hair without
the big lather the harsh ingredients of
typical shampoo and for the rest of your
shower routine you can use their body
washes they're free of harsh ingredients
they smell great and are refillable and
for after the shower protect your skin
from environmental stressors with
vitamin C plus e for Relic serum to keep
your skin looking young and healthy and
then a bit of dermatologist tested
aluminum free deodorant that really
smells great right now for a limited
time geologists is hooking our audience
up with an absolutely crazy offer use
the code new rock stars they will give
you an additional 70 off their
award-winning skincare trial set that
discount applies whether you're stocking
up for yourself or stuffing someone
else's stocking instead either way
geology has you covered check out their
awesome gift sets featuring all of your
favorite geology products to get started
just click the link in the description
take a 30 second diagnostic quiz and
their team of dermatologists will design
a personalized routine just for you that
ships directly to your door then the
shot of Oppenheimer followed by
photographers so the Manhattan Project
was top secret obviously but after the
bombs were dropped on Japan Oppenheimer
and other nuclear scientists became
famous public figures their faces on the
cover of magazines historically
oppenheimer's most famous quote is a
televised speech that he gave in 1965.
this was years after he was stripped of
his security clearance as a result of
his crusade to end the use of nuclear
weapons Oppenheimer was recounting what
was running through his mind after
witnessing the successful Trinity test
in July 1945. we knew the world would
not be the same
few people laughed
a few people cried
most people were silent
I remembered the line from the Hindu
scripture of the bhagavad-gita
Vishnu
is trying to persuade the prince that
he should do his duty
and to impress him
takes on his multi-armed form
and says
now I am become death
the destroyer of worlds
I suppose we all thought that one way or
another
go back to this footage Oppenheimer says
here Terry will take you only so far I
don't know
you trusted your weapon and we see the
pulsing anxiety being experienced by
Oppenheimer who despite his later
revulsion against using Atomic and
nuclear weaponry at the time really he
felt more pressure to be successful at
first to race to build the bomb before
the Nazis could but then after Germany
was defeated in early 1945 Oppenheimer
expressed regret that they weren't able
to build the bomb sooner to end that
front of the war and at this point in
summer 1945 he was worried how many
lives were being lost every day in the
Pacific Theater and felt they needed to
finish this bomb to end the war so
really in this film Oppenheimer is
suffering from Twin anxieties the
pressure to finish the job as quickly as
possible but then beyond that the deeper
dread of what he's gonna unleash upon
the world and I like here notice how
Nolan shows that by having oppenheimer's
chair tremble with radiation then we see
more light spinning nuclear fission has
never looked more beautiful specifically
it kind of looks like it could be taking
place in outer space because fission is
also part of the universal Forge that
causes stars to burn and emit light a
cosmic ballet a fission and fusion
Oppenheimer Ducks from an unexpected
explosion during testing I think this
might be one of the instances the
Trinity site was accidentally bombed by
the US military because it was so close
to a bombing range and so few people
knew that they were on this Mesa doing
what they were doing various shots of
Oppenheimer overseeing the construction
and rigging of the detonation Tower at
the Trinity site intercut with Gorgeous
slow motion shots of the vision process
there's also a few shots of Jack Quaid
as Richard thaneman this was the
Princeton theoretical business recruited
for the Manhattan Project who oversaw
the uranium enrichment process and as
the Trinity explosion happens an
observer puts on dark sunglasses as he
watches reportedly the sky lit up
brighter than daytime colors changing
from purple to green and eventually to
White and the base camp reportedly felt
as hot as an oven which is why this guy
is sweating so much the trailer ends on
the title
yeah the release date appears with the
sounds of radiation croaking in through
a geiger counter it reminds me of how
for the HBO series Chernobyl the
composer made that music for the series
by using sound that was recorded from
the Chernobyl site in pripyat so I am
both terrified and excited to see this
film in July let me know your thoughts
about it in the comments below you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at EA
boss follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you